we go
you forget to continue risk
is more dedicated to painting everything that
you will see
Y
everything started in a speleological conference
but that's where we get to the
school directly with all the
equipment to paint
beyond a seabird is touching me
much to the concentration will be 100%
mentally
I never thought
get to paint something like that
I started to like the child
painting drawings and I started painting
mountains but I said there are many
I wanted to be a good pitol
of the cartoonist
but a good painter wants to be different
and of a scripture is that for the first
once is also doctor has widely
a lot of evidence that is still missing
make known what I'm still going to
continue to paint this project in my country
continues to grow and will grow more
the escape albiol artist